I'll warm up with a few easy examples of
multiplying fractions or multiplying rational numbers -
a rational number is just another way to say
"liver", this is any number that can be expressed
as a liver.
And then we will solve a textual task that deals with
the multiplication of fractions.
Let us decide part a.
5/12 at 9/10.
The fun thing about multiplying and dividing
of fractions, at least for me, is that it's easier than collecting
or subtraction, literally simply multiplying the numerators,
when multiplying, and multiplying the denominators.
So you can say that this is the same thing as 5 * 9
on 12 * 10.
And we can simply multiply these, 45/120.
But it will not be the simplest type.
We will multiply these large numbers.
And before we do that we can divide the numerator
the number denominator, which will simplify them a little.
Let's do that.
If we divide the numerator and the denominator into 5, then
this will become 1, and this will be 2.
If we divide the numerator and the denominator into 3,
this will be 3, and this will become 4.
So this whole thing was simplified to 1 * 3, which
is 3 on ... 4 * 2, 3/8, which is a lot easier
than 45/120.
All right.
Let us decide part with.
(3/4) * (1/3).
We can fully apply the same principle.
This will be 3 * 1 on 4 * 3.
We can skip a step if we want and cut the threes in
numerator and denominator.
You divide the numerator and the denominator into 3.
You can say that this is 1 and this is 1.
And you will say that 1/4 of 1, 1 on 1 is equal to 1/4.
And here I missed one step, but in general I just said,
that it would be the same thing as 3 * 1
on 4 * 3.
You divide the numerator and denominator of
3 and you get 1/4.
That's exactly the same thing.
I'll decide f and just to finish things.
is is (1/13) * (1/11).
We just multiply the numerators.
We get 1 as 13 * 11.
Let's see, 13 * 10 is 130 and you have to
we have another one here.
So it would be 143 if I calculated correctly.
Yes, 13 * 10 is 130.
Yes.
It seems to me right.
Okay, one more to warm up.
All right.
I will decide part f.
(7/27) * (9/14).
We can apply the same trick we applied here.
You divide the numerator and the denominator into 7, so that
becomes 1, and this becomes 2.
Then we can divide the numerator and the denominator
at 9, this becomes 1, and this becomes 3.
This becomes 1 * 1 on 3 * 2 or 1/6.
Or you can just say 7 * 9, which is 63, on
27 * 14, which is a large number I do not know
the exact number and it would take a long time
to shorten it to the simplest look.
But this way, when you divide it in advance, it is
quite simply.
Let's solve a textual problem.
It includes monkeys.
"Three monkeys spent one day collecting
of coconuts together.
When they were over, they were a lot
tired and asleep.
The next morning the first monkey wakes up.
He does not want to bother his friends and decides to split
cocoons in three equal stacks.
There is one redundant, so throw it,
takes his share and returns. "
This is the third monkey.
He divides what he sees into three stacks.
We do not know how many in each pile.
Cup 1, Stack 2, Stack 3.
And then there was an extra coconut he threw.
This is a coconut here.
This first monkey divides the coconuts of
three equal stacks.
There was one redundant one, so he threw it,
takes his share and returns.
Its share is, let's say, take that share
throws this away.
That tells us.
He decides to divide the cocoons into three equal
piles, there is one redundant and throws it,
and then he takes his share.
All right.
"A few minutes later, the second monkey wakes up.
She does not realize what the first one did, so he also divides
cocoons in three equal stacks.
One remains, he throws it and
takes his share.
He finds one remaining coco, throws it,
This is the second monkey.
That's all he sees.
He sees these two stacks.
He divides these into three equal stacks.
Perhaps this is a heap here, it is - let me do it
slightly more equal.
This is a pile, these are two stacks and this -
in fact, he also sees that there is an extra coconut here.
Let me make it clear.
He finds one superfluous, finds that there is an extra coconut,
then the rest - remember, it's over
it's over.
We're only dealing with this at the moment.
One redundant and three equal piles.
One pile, two stacks and three piles.
And then he takes this for himself.
Take one for yourself and take the excess coconut
then throw it away.
Now that's all we have left.
And then you can guess what's going on.
"In the morning the third monkey wakes up and sees it
she is alone.
He notices the two eaten coconuts and places them
in the stack. "
Interesting.
"He puts them in the pile, and that
gives him a total of 12 cocoons. "
That is, he notices this and that, putting them
back into the pile.
This is the first - or perhaps I must say -
this is the first monkey or three monkeys - in fact,
I must say that this is the first monkey.
The first monkey did this, then the second monkey now
we're dealing with the third monkey.
He notices the two discarded cocoons and places them
in the stack that gives her a total of 12.
This is the third monkey, the third one that wakes up.
I'm sorry if I confused you.
This one woke up first, there was one redundant one
with three equal piles.
One superfluous holds one for himself.
The second monkey sees these cocoons, makes three equal
piles, there is one redundant.
Then the third monkey wakes up, sees these two cocoons,
and then he sees what's in the stack and he's there
a total of 12 cocoons.
So they ask us: "How many cocoa have taken
the first and second monkeys? "
All right.
Actually let me make it clear.
There are 12 cocoons in total.
Here are 12 coconuts after they are taken
those who were thrown.
That's 12, this must be 10 cocoa.
That's 10 coco and if you look at these two
stacks that are left, this must be 5 cocoons,
5 coconut and he has taken 5 cocoons.
And if you get to this point here, how many coco
were they there?
There must have been 15 plus this 1 coco here.
The first monkey must have had 16 cocoons
in these two piles.
This must have been 8 and 8.
And then he took an equal share of 8.
For starters, we had 8 * 3, 24 cocoa plus 1.
We started with 25 cocoa.
This one took 8, then we had 16 cocoons.
He has taken 8, discarded 1, so there were only 16 left.
The second monkey has come and told her she will
divided them into 3 groups of 5.
There is one redundant one.
He picks 5.
Then you have 10 remaining, plus the two discarded and total 12.